[Applause]
all right new rule any Fixer immigration
must be bipartisan Hillary Clinton must
contribute all her unsold books to
building a wall and Democrats must allow
ace goalie Tim Howard to set up on the
border and keep out those kids new rules
someone has to put a stop to those
internet ads that cover an entire
website and stay there until you manage
to find and click that tiny little
button wait it's like trying to locate
your computer's g-spot I just hope this
gimmick ends before it spreads to other
media because Oh for crying out loud
somebody click that would you please
sure it went better in rehearsal new
rule you could make a good case for
cutting the balls off a cat but you
can't pretend it makes the cat cool this
is scooter the new mascot for neutering
your cat he's got sunglasses a big gold
necklace and he's covered in fur
oh wait that's not a cat that's the
Armenian guy who sold me my cell phone
can I bring it back on new rules stop
saying Obama's handshake with the
horse's head was his weirdest meeting of
the week that was the next thing when he
met with the horse's ass
neural new rule NASA one in five people
in the UK admitted they would have sex
with a robot inflatable glove dolls a
stop looking so surprised
what's the prophecy